next our each other I renege we'll talk
talk about our fine spline insight into
the attorney Oh Mike max it's great to
be here how can everybody hear me at the
back okay yeah it's great to be here
really looking forward at this meeting
that is part of a program on foundations
of deep learning and and what I'd like
to do is just talk a little bit about
some of the progress we've been making
trying to find a language a language we
can use to describe what we're learning
as we scratch away at these black box
deep learning systems that have been
promised to catapult us into going into
the end of the future right and what I'm
gonna argue is splines provide a very
natural framework for both describing
what we've learned but also providing us
avenues for extending both the design
and analysis of a whole host of
different deep learning systems and so
I'm going to talk a little bit about a
particular kind of spline today and then
I'm gonna give you a whole bunch of
apples of how we've been using it to
describe and extend and of course we're
not the first people to think about the
relationship with deep nets or neural
nets and splines this goes way back to
pre the the previous deep net winter but
I think that we have you know
particularly we've identified a combat a
collection of particularly useful
splines for modern deep nets
okay so just let's jump in and talk
about the basic set up so we all know
that deep nets solve a function
approximation problem we're trying to
use training data to approximate the
prediction function from data to some
prediction might be a regression problem
might be a classification problem and we
do this in a hierarchical way through a
number of layers in a network and what
I'm going to argue is that deep net
do this in a very particular kind of way
using a spline approximation so show of
hands how many people here know about
splines okay so there's two key parts to
a spline approximation the first is a
partition of the input space or the
domain so if X is just a one-dimensional
input variable then we have a partition
Omega in this case we're splitting the
domain up into four different regions
we're now the second important thing is
there a local mapping that we use to
approximate some in this case function
so we have a blue function we want to
approximate here and we approximate it
we're gonna be interested in piecewise a
fine or piecewise linear splines by just
in this case four piecewise of fine
mappings okay makes sense to everybody
but really this yin-yang relationship
between the partition and the mapping
that that works the magic in splines
there's two big classes of splines
there's the really powerful splines for
example free not splines this is where
you let the partition be arbitrary and
this and then what you do is you jointly
optimize both the partition and the
local mapping these are the most allow
you to have the highest quality
approximation but it's important to note
that they're computationally intractable
in 1d in fact in hired even dimensions
to an above it's not even clear how to
define what a free not spline is so
these are something we'd really like to
be able to do but very very difficult
typically what people do is they they
fall back to some kind of gritting type
technique and if you think of even what
wavelets are they're really just a
dyadic grid approximation type of spline
so what we're going to focus on today is
a particular family of splines that we
call we don't call that we're kind
maxify splines by Stephen Boyd a number
of years ago and these were developed
just for the idea of approximating a
convex function with a continuous
piecewise affine approximation okay so
let's do continue with this really
simple example to just define a max of
fine
spline we're interested in approximating
this could convex function over R
capital R regions so we assume that we
have our affine functions these are
parameterised by a set of slopes and a
set of biases we're gonna have our set
to those here's an example for R equals
four we have four separate four of these
distinct affine functions and if the key
thing about the reason why we call the
maxify splines is very conveniently if
we want to approximate a convex function
by these splines all we have to do is
take the maximum the vertically highest
in this case I find function okay so if
you think of these four f-find functions
that we thrown down here and we think of
approximating this blue curve all we're
going to be using is simply the top
right the piece that actually sits on
the top okay and so the really important
thing here is that it's just by fixing
these four sets of slopes and biases we
this automatically generates an implicit
partition of the input space right yet
you switch from one partition region to
the next whenever these affine functions
cross and that's gonna be you know
really important for laters this makes
sense to everybody
very very simple right of course this
also gives a continuous approximation so
let's just think a little bit about
pointing towards deep nets without going
to a lot of details just imagine so
we're still in one dimension and we take
our input X we scale by a add a bias B
and then pass it through a ray loop
right this operation here well it's
pretty easy to show that this is a max
affine spline approximation with R
equals to a find functions the first is
being 0 0 is the flat function 0
function and then the second being
basically that think of this like a like
like the Ray Lu but now shifted over and
with the slope change by the parameter a
two okay so just this should get your
yourself thinking about other deep net
operations and whether they can
be related to the max affine splines
we're going to define a max if I'm
spline operator simply by concatenating
K of these max affine splines so you can
think of an input vector now we're no
longer in 1d X is in D dimensions and
then we have K different splines the and
the output of each of those splines will
just be one entry of this output vectors
Z we're gonna call that Amazo or a max
affine spline operator so what's the key
key realization well let's start by just
talking about deep nets okay if you
think of the lion's share of what the
deep nets that are used today basically
any architecture you can think of using
piecewise linear or you know affine
operators fully connected operators
convolution operators leaky Ray leaky
Ray Lu or Ray Lu absolute value any of
these types of pooling z-- these are all
built these the state-of-the-art methods
are all built out of these kind of
architectures and these kind of
operators and it's actually pretty easy
to show that all of these operators that
comprise the layers of bit essentially
all of today's state-of-the-art deep
nets are maxify spline operators you can
think of then each layer of a deep net
is just a max affine spline operator and
so that what we're doing is we're doing
that we have a convex approximation
going on at each of these layers and
therefore a deep net is just a
composition of maxify spline operations
no longer a convex operator because
composition of two convex operators
isn't necessarily convex okay so so this
is gonna so we're just going to call
this in a fine spline operator it
remains continuous but it doesn't have
this max affine spline property anymore
I just as an aside if you wanted the
overall net to be convex it's pretty
easy to constraint to show that all you
need to do is just ensure that the all
of the weights in the second layer and
onward are positive number
right that guarantees that the overall
mapping will be convex any questions
about this very simple baseline stuff
okay so they'll recall the nice thing
about these these particular splines is
that as soon as you fix the parameters
right the slopes and the offsets
wherever those hyper planes are these
affine varieties cross that defines a
partition and that's really where things
get interesting right is to think about
the partitioning that goes on in these
maxify spline operators because that
allows us to think a lot about the
geometry of what's going on in a deep
network so again just reiterating what I
just said if you think about a set of
parameters of a deep network layer
they're gonna automatically induce a
partition of the input space of that
particular layer into convex regions and
then if you compose several of these
layers we're going to form a non convex
partition of of the input space and and
this provides really interesting
non-trivial links to classical ideas out
of signal processing information theory
computational geometry namely ideas like
vector quantization k-means and and
Voronoi tiles and we'll get into these
as we go so one of the yeah key ideas is
linking these modern deep net ideas back
to more classical signal processing
ideas so let's just do a toy example so
that you can visualize what goes on in
one of these vector quantization
partitions of the input spaces so let's
just consider a toy example a
three-layer net we go from an input
space it's two-dimensional we're gonna
four classes in the two dimensional
input 2d just so we can visualize can't
visualize really anything beyond 3d we
go to a layer of 45 units then three
units and then we're gonna do a four
class classification problem so we have
four units on the output okay makes
sense to everybody so this is the inputs
this is what goes on in the input space
we have four different classes with
these four colors our goal is to build a
classifier to to tell these apart
this is the first axis of the input
space the second axis and this is what
happens after we go through the first
layer right the we go to 45 this the
layer the Maslow layer that map's the
input to the output of this first layer
this is the vector quantization
partition or the spline partition that
you that that that you obtain
importantly we're going through a single
layer so the tiling is convex right
these are convex regions right makes
sense okay moreover let's remember that
these are splines after all so we can
ask what what is the mapping from the
input of the first layer to the output
of the first layer well it's just a very
simple affine map because it's an affine
spline after all okay that once you know
a signal right a particular ax lands in
this particular tile right there is a
that that gives you a particular matrix
a right and a offset vector B right that
are different for every VQ tile but then
the mapping for the input to the output
of that layer is just simply this affine
map so you can think of a the mapping
from the input to the output of one deep
knit layer is just a VQ dependent affine
transformation so this is one layer so
now if we go through two layers and we
think of the partition induced on the
input space we now see that we start
picking up non-convex or we start having
non convex regions because the
non-convex operator however we still
have the same concept right that if a
signal falls in this particular tile
right this particular partition region
the mapping from the input to the output
of the second layer remains just simply
in affine map right where the a and the
B are indexed by this particular tile
and just to be SuperDuper clear about it
one more time every signal that lives in
this tile that falls in this tile on the
input space has the exact same
f-fine mapping okay and this is what
happens when you learn just to
see when you if you initialize with
random random weights zero biases you
just get a set of cones and as we go
through learning epochs you see that we
end up with these cones pulling away
from the origin and then cones being cut
up by other cones and we result again
and for at least layers wanted to this
particular mapping it at convergence
okay and I'm gonna III think that it's
really thinking of this geometrical
picture is really very useful to think
about the inner workings of what's going
on in a in a deep network in particular
a deep net is a VQ mer machine right
it's computing a vector quantization so
was their question yeah we said oh let
me just think if I got this right we set
all the biases to zero in the whole in
the whole network yeah so we'll just
still it's still there's no beat there's
no box set so it's just gonna remain
yeah calling the corners of Collins is
just calm that makes sense okay good so
let's talk a little bit about some of
the geometrical properties you can
actually delve deeper into the what the
structure of these VQ tiles and show
that that the part of the partition of
each of a single layer right a single
layers input space in terms of the
output is something called it's actually
not a Voronoi diagram it's something
called power diagram question anybody
here heard of power diagrams okay
fantastic so it's a generalization of a
Voronoi diagram now instead of just
having a centroid it has a centroid and
a radius all right so it's a it's a mild
generalization of a Voronoi tiling but
the basically you just compute a Voronoi
tiling but with something called a genre
distance instead of the standard
Euclidean distance but the tiles remain
convex convex polytopes
right and
in high dimensional space moreover given
these affine maps given the the entries
in these a matrices and these B bias
vectors we have there they're close form
formulas for the centroids and the radii
that determine all of these polytopes so
you can understand you can study the the
geometry of these the the eccentricity
the size etc by thanks to the in closed
form thanks to these formulas moreover
it should be pretty clear that since
you're piling layers upon layers that
the the pop the power diagram formed
from let's say two Mazal layers applied
in composition is going to be formed by
a subdivision process because the
cutting of the cuts from the second
layer input of the second layer to the
output will basically cut the vq tiling
from the first layer right and so this
is just an example of an input space
tiling first layer will just be a set of
straight line cuts the second layer is
going to be a subdivision of those cuts
we colored them gray here subdivision
but now the important thing is that the
cuts are going to be bent right they're
going to be bent at the gray bond arees
which are the boundaries defined by the
first layer cuts and these by these
bends you can actually compute bounds
for example on the dihedral angles and
and these bends are precisely two main
continent to maintain continuity of the
mapping from the input to the output of
this operator if you didn't have these
bending then you could have the spline
become non continuous okay but again
these bends are very important and they
have a lot to do with weight sharing in
deep deep networks so one of the
conclusions you can just take away from
this part partway through is that deep
networks are really a very practical
very efficient way of doing something
that is extremely difficult which is
free not spline approximation and Heidi
all right that's
that's that's really what deep deep
networks are doing you could carry this
all the way to the last layer in a
classification problem say it study the
decision boundary of the deep net it is
again just going to be one of these
basically just one of these cuts and you
can understand for example the the
smoothness of the boundary by the fact
that the you can you can only have so
much bending between the cuts when you
cut through the power diagram partition
that you obtained from the previous
regions there's lots of things that can
be done to understand for example
smoothness of the
decision boundaries in different kinds
of deep Nets this is one direction that
we've been exploring the other is
looking in particular at these affine
mappings so again when you're in in a VQ
tile you know that there's for all
signals that live in that tile there's
just a fine map that goes from the input
to the output
what what what what properties can we do
for me glean from these okay so in
particular if we think let's just study
the the simple the the case of input to
the output of the entire network okay
which we'll call this Z big L you can
ignore the softmax that doesn't really
enter into any of the the discussions
I'm gonna bring up but we're interested
in the mapping through all the layers of
the network the this affine mapping
formula applies no matter where you are
in the network you'll just have
different A's and B's but we're
interested in the one from the input to
the very output okay from the input to
the very output well you can develop
closed-form formulas for this map
particularly for a continent this is
what the a the a matrix looks like this
is what this offset B looks like we can
know all of these matrices here in close
form so you can do different kinds of
analyses for example look at the
Lipschitz stability two different points
in the network based on different inputs
but the thing I'm most interested in
talking about here is what what are the
rows of this a matrix look like because
if you think about this what is the
output of the deep net
right everything up until the the
softmax
well it's basically just a matrix a
multiplied just ignore this typo it's
this matrix a multiplied by my signal ax
plus a bias
well that then that this is just a
vector how big is this vector is one
output for every class right I and what
how do I determine which class the input
is it's whichever of these outputs is
largest right okay so let's think we
have a matrix a that we're multiplying
by our X each entry in this output is
what just a inner product of a row of a
with X so what is that right if we think
about this matrix a
well the C throw right course buying a
Class C is dist we're just going to take
the inner product of the C throw with X
in order to get the C output of Z we
want to find the biggest what's the
what's the the what do we call this in
signal processing nomenclature we call
this a match filter bank right because
basically what we're doing is we're
applying to our signal a set of filters
by inner products cauchy-schwarz tells
us that the more the filter looks like
the input the larger the output is going
to be okay and the optimal filter is
what where the row is exactly the input
right standard standard stuff that's
done in you know radar signal processing
sonar walk communication systems etc and
you can actually visualize this in a
real network so this is just see far ten
here's an input of an airplane here's
the row this that this is the the row of
the corresponding a matrix for that
input vector unvectorized so that it
looks like an image see it looks if you
squint it looks a lot like an airplane
okay I have a large inner product if you
look at these other rows corresponding
ship class dog class you see they don't
actually look like a ship or a dog but
more like a anti-air plane all right in
order to push down the inner product
largest inner product smallest even
smaller inner product
in fact I yes sir I didn't talk about
the bias but the way to think about the
bias is if if you're a Bayesian then the
B's would be related to the prior
probabilities of the different classes
so if you knew that that planes were
very very likely you would put you would
load B with a large number in the beef
the beef entry that make sense yeah yeah
Renee yeah so it's subtle it's subtle
but you could think of this as like a
dictionary learning machine that's
basically given an input is is is
defining then a bit of Bayesian
classifier does that help a little bit
okay so and of course if you if you
think what these rows of these a matrix
matrices are and you think of the fact
that we're decomposing the deep net
input output relationship in terms of
affine maps there's a just a direct link
between the rows of this a matrix and
what are called saliency maps by by the
the community so it gives new intuition
behind what goes on or what happens when
we when we think about salience email
moreover if you if you if you you can
prove a simple result that says if you
have a high capacity deep net that's
capable of producing basically any and
arbitrary a matrix if you will from a
from a given input then you can show
that the Seath role of the a matrix when
you input a piece of training data xn is
going to become exactly xn when you're
on the true class right X is late X ends
label and essentially minus a constant
times xn when you are not in when you're
in a different class
and so this is this will tell us a
little bit both about again reinforcing
this match filter interpretation but
also helping us understand a little bit
about this memorization memorization
process okay a couple more a couple more
points so another thing we can do is we
can think now because we under we can
have formulas for these affine Maps we
can characterize the prediction function
f that map's the input to the output and
we can think of different kind of
complexity measures that we can derive
out of these affine mapping formulas so
there's a lot of applications for
complexity measures for example you
might want to compare two deep networks
one which has a very complicated
prediction function the other that
solves the same task but has a much
simpler prediction function
Occam's razor type idea we might also
want to apply a complexity measure as a
penalty directly to our to our learning
process right so there's a large
literature of deriving different
complexity measures and complexity
penalties for deep nets all this point
to you know two of them as examples one
is there's a very nice recent paper that
that links the the ubiquitous to norm to
norm of the weights penalty for learning
to a particular measure of the second
derivative of the prediction function
all right so that it really does say
that for at least a very very simple
kind of network there's a link between
the weight values of the weights and the
wiggliness of s and then there's another
school of approaches that looks at well
we have a VQ tiling of the input space
let's count the number of tiles because
presumably the more codes there are in
your code book the more tiles there are
the more complicated the function that
you're trying to approximate so these
are two approaches well I'm going to get
one that really expands upon these two
and it it is leveraging the fact that we
can was leveraging really the the fact
that lots of data sets of particular
image type data sets we have a
reasonable reasonably true property that
the the the training data live on low
lowered that doesn't that be low
dimensional but lower dimensional
manifold sub manifolds of the high
dimensional space okay so let's assume
that our data lives not filling up the
entire input space but living on some
lower dimensional sub manifold or sub
manifolds and in this case we can we can
look into the manifold learning
literature and there's a beautiful paper
by Donna Hahn crimes that defines what's
called the Hessian eigen map manifold
learning technique which is is basically
trying to flatten a curvy manifold using
the tangent a CN along the manifold so
we can just a dot this this same measure
and we can define a complexity measure C
as the integral of the of the tangent
hessian along the manifold so you can
just think of it roughly speaking is the
low look you have F it's a peacefull at
the continuous piecewise defined
function and what we're looking at is
the local deviation of F from flat so f
if f of X was a completely flat function
this measure would be 0 if F was very
very jagged II meaning locally when you
look over a few regions it's jumping up
and down wildly this will be a large
this will be a large number yes well
simply by integrating along this
basically we're just integrating along
the tangent manifold part
yes yes yeah and you could also you know
just integrate over the entire space but
then you lose some of the nice some of
the nice properties did that help oh
yeah and we could talk we can talk about
after so the nice thing about this
measure is that you can develop a marker
a Monte Carlo approximation in terms of
the training data points the X ends that
are your training data point and the
affine mapping parameter so it's
actually extremely easy to actually
compute the value of C given a set of
trained training points and giving the
affine mapping parameters no I won't
left it just think of P is true for
right now so it's all the ideally you
will choose the P depending on
particular for example the manifold
dimension the ambient dimension week
yeah let's talk about it at the break
this is a date let's the data manifolds
assume the training data or samples from
some sub manifold in the in the ambient
space because there are two factors that
can increase C one is f there is the
many other you mean the smoothness of
the manifold say yeah absolutely but but
if if we just assume let's just say you
have to to prediction functions and
their domain in both cases is the same
manifold and that would be normalized
out right yes yeah are you no longer
working with values here
this is where rail is absolutely or
piecewise peaceful a convex piecewise a
fine nonlinear fashion then zero
everywhere I know yeah let's talk about
let's talk about it offline
I think otherwise I'll run out of time
yeah well it won't be yeah okay so let's
let's look at an application of this to
something that is I would say somewhat
still mysterious in the deep learning
world and that is data the data
augmentation so if we think of how deep
networks are trained today they're
typically trained with this technique
called data augmentation that we don't
just feed in images of been right we
feed in images of translates right of
been rotations have been etc and if we
have a hypothesis that the images have
been somehow came from a lower
dimensional manifold in high dimensional
space where points on that manifold were
translates and rotations of each other
then the it's very convenient that these
augmented data points that are generated
from just your raw initial training data
will live on the same data manifold okay
so there's a in this particular setting
you can you can prove a result that says
that just starting with date writing out
the the cost of say cross-entropy cost
function with data augmentation terms
you can actually develop that those data
augmentation terms and pull them out of
the first part of the cost function and
show that they basically form a this
Hessian penalty this Hessian complexity
regularization penalty okay so what
that's saying is that data augmentation
implicitly implements a hessian
complexity regularization on the
optimization okay so that's like the
theorem here too or just a simple
experiment with the CFR 100 data
that so this is training epochs in the
x-axis this complexity measure in the
vertical axis and all we're doing here
is we are as we're training the network
trained trained without data
augmentation in black and with data
augmentation in blue what we're looking
at are based on the A's and the B's that
we have the that we have learned with
the network we're plugging that into our
complexity measure that was on the
previous previous slide and we're seeing
that the measure is showing that the
network that has learned using data
augmentation has far lower complexity
than the network that has learned with
data augmentation this is both on the
training and on the test data yeah we're
doing the station depends on the loss
and is these anticipation arising due to
two square lows oh yeah good question
well in this case we it was it was cross
entropy loss it wasn't that wasn't weird
work with rotations of two similar
images have the same label yeah so the
loss in comparative labels and so that
has to change the regularization has to
change to the same
yeah let's yeah so so for just for now
the interest of time let's just assume
cross-entropy loss for a classification
problem rather than l2 l2 loss for a
regression problem and then let me think
and maybe I'll have a better answer by
the time that we get to question yeah
complex measure is only a function of
the model but not a lot is that right
absolutely yes - okay so let's one last
quick quick note what can we do beyond
piecewise defined deep nets because
sigmoid hyperbolic tanh these are still
very useful in certain applications in
particular in recurrent deep nets and it
turns out that you can bring those under
the same umbrella that of this max
affine spline framework and the way to
do that is to switch from a
deterministic hard vector quantization
approach or way of thinking where if X
lives in a in this particular vector
quantization tile it definitively lives
in that vector quantization tile to a
soft VQ approach where now we just we
have a probability that X will fall in a
given vector quantization tile where for
this particular signal maybe there's a
high probability in this tile somewhat
smaller in the local local region a
burring tiles and then decreasing
probability as you move away so if you
just set up a very simple Gaussian
mixture model where the means and
covariances are based on these A's and
B's that we derive you can you can
basically derive nonlinearities like the
sigmoid like the softmax directly from
Ray Lu absolute value and other
piecewise defined convex nonlin
non-linearity's and in particular if you
if you do a look at a hybrid approach
it's this between a hard vq and a soft
vq alright with where you're basically
blending between the two you can
generate infinite classes of interesting
and potentially useful nonlinearities
and I'll just point out one how many
people here have heard of the swish
non-linearity a few so this was a
non-linearity that was discovered a few
years ago through an empirical search
that's the empirical search for is there
a normal in the area that works better
than Ray Lu right for large-scale
classification problems and it turned
out there there there was and it was a
fairly sizable you know non-trivial gain
in a lot of cases and it's this black
dashed line here and the interesting
thing it's hard to know if it's a
coincidence or not but if you look at
the in some sense the midway point
between hard VQ and South vq i based on
the the Ray Lu function at the hard VQ
side and the sigmoid gated linear unit
at the soft vq the swish is precisely
halfway in between it's quite quite ok
you could also pull out sigmoid
hyperbolic tangent by adopting a
probabilistic viewpoint of the output of
a layer no longer being just a
deterministic output of the input but
instead the probabilities that you fall
in the different VQ regions in the input
that's what we can do beyond piecewise
so I better wrap up so what I hope to
get across is that this spline in
particular max affine splined viewpoint
can provide a useful language to talk
about the things that we're learning
about deep networks but also frame the
kind of questions that we would like to
move forward with my talked a bit about
the the basic you know framework of max
affine splines and deep nets I talked
about the relationships with with vector
coin
sation and really that a deep net is you
could think of it as a vector
quantization machine or you could think
of it as a free not spline machine
there's there really I think interesting
links between power diagrams from
computational geometry and the the
subdivision that's generated by this
layer upon layer max affine spline
process this the affine transformations
that we derive based on that these
difficulties different vq regions allow
us to link deep nets back to old-school
signal processing ideas like match
filter banks and they allow us to define
new kinds of complexity measures in
particular this Hessian measure that we
talked about it's all in there and say
there's some some papers that people
would like to take a peek and I'd be
happy to answer any additional questions
[Applause]
it's all really a question the second
derivative of that one so yeah so the
basically the the way the way that we
think about it is that you have a it's
okay there's there's let's stop it to
hear a heuristic way of thinking about
it is if you had a piecewise-defined
function it's gonna be undefined that
obviously kinks right but if you thought
if you think of basically here some
heuristic way to smooth any heuristic
way you can think of to smooth out that
kink then the second derivative is going
to be related to the slope parameters on
one side and the soul parameters on the
other side with yeah exactly and the
bandwidth of this movie that's the
epsilon that was in that in that formula
there's a there there details that we
could you know we could talk about the
brain
yes
[Music]
you mean the bat like how large the
measure yeah so that was what this yeah
that the point of this experiment was
really to look at ads as we are training
so as we're going through training
affects what is happening you know what
is the value of in this case the value
of this complexity measure as we train
the network through the various training
training cycles both with in this case
with data augmentation and in this case
without data augmentation does that make
sense
no you just so it just in a nutshell
think of think of a Gaussian mixture
model a Gaussian mixture model defined
in terms of covariance means and
covariances we're now the means and
covariances are defined in terms of
these different tiles pardon me so okay
what's the best way to describe it so
start from start from a hard VQ where we
have a tiling now you have because of
the power diagram you have a radius and
you have a centroid now use that radius
in that centroid as the per to develop a
Gaussian mixture model for example a you
know circle a symmetric Gaussian mixture
with that particularly the radius being
the the variance now under that if you
think in terms of now under that model
you'll have a given an input you can
think about the probability that it
falls into each of these individual
tiles will be determined by the
probability under that particular each
of those mixtures does that make sense
and if you put if you now look at these
probabilities these probabilities behave
like in the case of say you start with
the tiling derive from array Lu you will
you will end up with set of
probabilities that are that that follow
the functional form of a sigmoid gated
linear unit in that case does that help
that is not funny it's already trained
you can mean there is no time right oh
okay okay
you know you I my question is I assume
there is a procedure to arrive so can we
go backwards you're saying I need to
think about that yeah we were thinking
only in the one in one direction going
from a hard v q to a soft vq presumably
you could reverse that process by if you
have a certain kind of but it would have
to be not all possible nonlinearities
are reachable via this saw this this
soft our relaxation of this hard v q
right you can't reach you can't reach
arbitrary you can't reach arbitrary
nonlinearities right only certain kind
of nonlinearities if you wanted to reach
arbitrary ones you would have to there's
no way you could do that with just a
ghost standard kind of Gaussian mixture
framework that help yeah
yes go back to the contacts to make sure
it was sure or are we here it's a very
good question um so it sounds like a
blood test
sorry for the low D a after one and
fifty ipok there's no number it is just
because of a proton so that's something
happen like oh oh sorry sorry yeah no we
jet this is an artifact of the plotting
we shall probably should have stopped a
plot here yeah
yes like a total number of examples yeah
so the that's a really good question
because in fact we're we're only the way
that we compute okay there's the
complexity measure and then there's the
computation of the approximation of the
complexity measure the more training
samples you have the more densely you
will sample the manifold the the signal
manifold and that closer your
approximation will be to the true
the true measure and so the more
training data that you have the closer
you'll get to the true measure yeah
that's a really good question
so there are methods that attempt to do
adaptive yawn selection movies like
Trent oh yeah and you can apply it with
some on occasions to multivariate data
and get adaptive finally yeah is there
some sense of so it would give you
similar results it's right hierarchical
VQ would be another yeah yeah but is
there some sense about the properties of
these quantizations and these timings
are that will differentiate you from
something that's that more directly
tries to penalize is that to me this is
this is the this is this is a really key
key unanswered question right what the
question was there that there are you
know there are a number of different
ways to try to find different free not
spline approximations in higher
dimensions and why are deepening of the
Oh Howard deep nets bet you know
different or better and this this is a
big question I answered question there
there's no question that the methods
that we use the you know current
training method
our optimization approaches are enabling
us to find these free not spline
approximations in there truly
ridiculously high dimensions right where
a lot of these other techniques you
wouldn't even attempt to them right but
still it does not mean that this is the
that we that we've stumbled on the best
way of doing this so I think that as we
think of new kinds of optimization
methods for example our new kinds of
architectures we're finding new ways to
hierarchically build up these these
blank partitions and eventually we'll
find out that there are some ways that
are better than other ways and we're
probably not even you know partway there
yet okay I guess this sexist speech
[Applause]